[Music]
now to our coverage of the coronavirus
in washington congressional democrats
are trying to push forward with the
president's covitt relief plan without
gop support
this as the administration works to ramp
up vaccine distribution nationwide
deborah alferon has the latest
the federal government is shipping out
an additional 500
000 coronavirus vaccines nationwide
so for the next three weeks we will
provide a minimum
of 10.5 million in total doses per week
white house covet 19 response
coordinator jeff zion says
they are also sending 1 million doses to
6 500 pharmacies
starting next week sites are selected
based on their ability to reach some of
the populations most at risk
40 000 pharmacies may eventually receive
direct
shipments health experts in indiana hope
it will help reach people
that hospitals and mass vaccination
sites might not
90 of hoosiers live within 10 miles of a
pharmacy
it basically cuts out the middleman the
white house is also working with
congress to pass a 1.9
trillion dollar relief bill president
biden told senate democrats that the
republican plan of about 600 billion
dollars is inadequate if we did a
package that small
we'd be mired in the covet crisis for
years
democrats are trying to pass their bill
through a process called reconciliation
which wouldn't require any republican
votes totally partisan
minority leader mitch mcconnell used the
same tools to pass the trump tax cuts
they are in the majority in the house
and senate and
life is a series of choices and they've
chosen democrats hope to pass a bill
by march before the unemployment
benefits from the last package
run out debra l ferrone cbs news
washington
president biden's proposal includes more
funding for schools to reopen
larger stimulus checks and more
unemployment benefits
republicans as you've heard they say
it's too expensive